thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much for taking the time
to join us today from the legislative
building in regina we'll have premier
scott mo as well as saskatchewan's chief
medical health officer dr shahab and
then we will take some time for
questions premier thank you
well good morning everyone and thank you
for joining us here here this morning
last september during what was a very
serious delta wave in saskatchewan our
government introduced a proof of
vaccination requirement in a number of
workplaces and and public venues across
the province when we first introduced
this policy i
would be the first to admit that i was
reluctant to do so i knew there would be
a much benefit from a policy such as
this in the fight against covet and at
that time the the delta wave
but i also knew that that benefit would
come with significant cost i knew that
this policy would recreate deep
divisions in our
families in our friendship groups in our
province and in communities across
saskatchewan
but
people would potentially have different
access
or rights based on what their relative
vaccination status would be that is the
result of that policy
so what what was actually a pretty
extraordinary step to take
in this province effectively created two
classes of citizens to my knowledge this
province has never done anything like
that before in our history
for any vaccine
or for any other reason for that matter
for our time
during that delta wave i do believe that
the benefits of this policy most
certainly did outweigh the costs there
were many more people that went out and
got vaccinated their first dose their
second dose and ultimately uh more
recently their their third or brewster
dose
and covert transmission was
significantly reduced as we found our
way through the delta wave last fall
but today as we deal with a very
different strain the omicron variant the
benefits of this policy no longer
outweigh the costs
many many many more people today are
vaccinated than they were prior to us
putting that policy in september the
16th 85 percent of those that are
eligible
in this province have received their
first dose 80 percent of those that are
eligible have received their second shot
and are now fully vaccinated and nearly
50 percent of those eligible have also
went out and received their booster dose
while vaccines are still widely
available in saskatchewan and they will
remain widely available across this
province
lately vaccine uptake has slowed to some
degree
and vaccination as we know is not
preventing transmission of omicron like
it did with previous variants and i will
continue to encourage everyone and
anyone that is eligible to go out and
get vaccinated your first your second
and ultimately your booster dose as
vaccines most certainly do provide
significant protection against serious
illness from omicron or any other
variant however if someone makes a
different choice
about whether or not they are vaccinated
that's their right
and this government is going to respect
that right
today with omicron the benefits of the
proof of vaccination policy no longer
outweigh the costs
this policy most certainly has run its
course
so it's time for us to take a step back
in living with covet and to get to make
every effort to get our lives back to
normal
it's time for us also to heal the
divisions in our communities over
vaccination those divisions are in our
families they're they yes they're in our
communities but they are across our
province and they're across this nation
it's time for us to come together as
families as friends as as communities
and as a province and as a nation and
it's time for us to reach out and
support one another
let's not judge our neighbor because
they may be vaccinated or because they
may not be vaccinated
let's not judge our neighbor if they
should choose to wear a mask or not to
choose to wear a mask in the weeks ahead
whenever someone is doing their own
personal risk assessment which we have
asked them to do in this province for a
period of time now
they're doing that assessment for
themselves possibly for their family and
they may come back with a a different
decision than what you might
arrive at and that different conclusion
albeit maybe different from where you
have landed
should not be judged
it should be respected
and it should be accepted
it's time for each of us as individuals
now to make a conscious effort to treat
everyone in our daily lives that we
encounter equally
it's also time for the proof of
vaccination mandate to end
so effective at midnight this sunday
february the 13th all provincial proof
of vaccination requirements will end
in saskatchewan businesses in venues and
provincially regulated workplaces this
means that the proof of vaccination or
the negative test option that we
provided will no longer
be a provincial requirement
starting on valentine's day february the
14th
this will be the case
this will leave one remaining covert
measure in place and that is indoor
masking
that measure remains in effect until the
end of february
i want to thank all of the businesses
and the venues and the workplaces who
have shifted course throughout this
pandemic to keep their employees and to
keep their customers safe and all those
who implemented and administered the
proof of vaccination or proof of
negative test policy over the course of
the past few months
thank you for doing your part in your
our fight against covet
and again i want to thank everyone who
made this choice
it is a wise choice to ultimately go out
and get vaccinated
you are keeping yourself safe
as we move into this next phase the
phase of now living with covet
i would ask you to continue
to make wise choices this is paramount
to our success
go get your booster dose if you haven't
already stay home if you're not feeling
well do a rapid test from time to time
if you do test positive we want you to
stay at home for five days
but let's all in the meantime also get
back to living our lives normally and
doing the things that we all
love to do
and let's all make that extra effort to
be just a little more understanding
of others when we may disagree
in fact this may well be our largest
challenge in getting our lives back to
normal in our in our families and our
communities in our friendship groups and
and in our province
we must realize that it's okay for us to
disagree we do hold strong opinions in
this province those are on full display
often but we can disagree without being
disagreeable
don't lose a friend to covet
you might have to take some time apart
but keep that door open
time and time again saskatchewan people
have proven that we achieve great things
when we come together and when we work
together and when we
accept those who may have a different
opinion
than we do
and when we respect others individual
decisions
we are poised to lead this nation
through covet
and we are poised to lead the world in
an economic recovery in this province
so let's work together
let's work together to heal some of the
divisions let's understand that we can
forgive our friends our family members
maybe even ourselves if that is
necessary let's work to heal those
divisions let's come together and let's
once again
be ourselves in our communities this is
a great province this is a united
province but most importantly this is a
tolerant province and we are going to
need all of that tolerance in the days
ahead
it's time for us to move
thank you
dr shahab do you have some comments
thank you premium i'll just clarify a
few things
um that um obviously vaccines remain
available five to eleven first second
doses
um additional roses as required first
fully immune compromised uh 12 and older
as announced today boosted those are
available for 12 to 17 they are
available five months after the second
dose so most uh 12 to 17 year olds got
this um second dose july august so there
shouldn't be any problem accessing that
um it's just a reminder here that the
online booking now is defaulting to five
months so if anyone 18 and older um
wants a booster before five months
they can call sasquatch one eight three
three seven two seven
five eight two nine to get a booster
if you're 18 or older after three months
um but 12 to 17 they can get a booster
after five months however 12 to 17 year
olds who was really compromised have
been eligible earlier for a booster at
three months and they will continue to
be so
um
and i think that is all just a reminder
that outbreaks will publicly be reported
only in long-term care
homes and personal care homes similar to
other respiratory outbreaks
and public health will continue to
investigate in those high-risk settings
including personal care homes shelters
and group homes
and just a reminder that
thursdays is when the weekly and
dashboard as we discussed last thursday
will be posted for a summary of
case numbers and trends over the last
seven days but that will be uh
up till
[Music]
sunday of the previous week so it will
be a weekly epidemiological survey
summary posted every thursday thank you
thank you premier thank you dr shahab
we'll now move to questions starting in
the room we'll start with larissa do you
have a question
um sure so as far as i'm aware this
morning saskatchewan is the first
province to remove this proof of acts
policy here um why is it that you think
that the province is ready for that and
why should we be the first province to
do that
well we're not removing it today it'll
be removed at midnight this sunday we're
the first province yes to announce that
we'll be moving in this direction i
think you will see other provinces uh
providing their citizens with what their
plan is on on how as as we see cases
decline in saskatchewan across canada as
we see hospitalizations decline in
saskatchewan and across canada i have no
doubt that you will see other provinces
putting forward what their plan is on uh
living with covet and and and taking
steps towards getting life back to
normal that will vary on given the the
individual cases uh that individual
situations that we see in in various
regions of of canada i would put forward
that the the federal government also um
should at some point in time be putting
uh forward what their plan is uh for the
federally
regulated uh industries as well on
behalf of canadians not um
because we should um we should as
canadians uh know you know where we are
going over the course of the next you
know number of weeks whether you work in
a provincially mandated sectors which is
what we control here today
or but also in in the the federally
mandated sector such as transportation
for example air travel
things of of that nature and so i think
you're going to see other provinces uh
quite likely come forward with uh you
know what the next number of weeks look
like in their respective jurisdictions
and i think in fairness you'll probably
see the the federal government as well
in the next while come forward with uh
what it looks like for those uh
those areas of our communities that are
regulated under under the uh the the
federal government
uh
as as we know with omicron we've been
over 20 months uh our story with covid
and not omicron but with covid proper
we've been dealing with this for for
close to two years now um you know
should things change in two three four
months um then ultimately uh we would
also we would have to continue to make
the best decisions in uh you know in
light of protecting our health care
capacity but
for today where we are with reducing
hospitalizations reducing numbers uh
we're confident as we move ahead with
this phased approach that we are going
to take these steps back to normal by
reducing and eliminating the public
health orders that are in place
but we'd also ask saskatchewan residents
to to be gracious and to understand that
everyone is doing their own personal
risk assessment and they might arrive at
a different conclusion than you and we
should accept that and we should respect
uh each and every one for the decisions
that they are making in their
environment
you have a follow-up question larissa um
yes i think it was so um you had stuff
in your earlier remarks that part of the
reason you were wanting to get rid of
this proof of acts policy was that
division between having baxed and
unbacked residents and the access that
causes
but it is a divisive topic there are
people who have very strong feelings
either way about having that policy or
not having it
um how do you see
that
the decision being made today to remove
that policy at the end of the week to
you know bring people together it's
obviously uh something that's kind of
dividing citizens just
so it
yeah so the the reason we're able to
remove this policies it's run its course
um it has increased our vaccination
rates in the province uh
substantially since it was uh introduced
as we found ourselves in the the delta
wave as we find ourselves in the in the
omicron wave which is much more
transmissible
uh the the two vaccines um do not
prevent uh in in any large way the the
the
transmissibility of covet but it most
certainly uh does help when it comes to
the um severe outcomes of of code so
this uh this policy has run its course
and it has enhanced the divisions on
whether you are not vaccinated by saying
uh if you want to go into let's say a
restaurant you're going to need a
negative test if you're if you're not
vaccinated you know as we move forward
um i would view whether or not you're
vaccinated against covet and very much
the same
scope as to whether or not you'd get a
flu vaccine each and every year
i don't think getting a flu vaccine is
in any way a divisive conversation in
the province
i often do virtually all the time i i do
get a flu vaccine simply because i i see
a lot of people um but i don't talk
about that um like we have with the the
quote whether or not we have a covet
vaccine and so i don't view it as a a
divisive conversation as we move forward
um i view it very much in in a similar
vein as to whether or not you got a flu
vaccine which seldom if ever comes up in
anyone's conversation and and but that's
going to take some effort um that's
going to take some individual effort and
i would ask everyone in this province to
make that effort um not focus and judge
or in any way uh
concern yourself with you know who is
vaccinated and ultimately who is not
vaccinated make your own personal risk
assessment for you and ultimately your
family
and that will be different for different
individuals depending on their age
whatever goes into that
that decision
and i i would ask people to do that and
i would also ask them not to in any way
judge anyone else for
the fact that post february 28th they
may be wearing a mask that's normalized
in our society it should be accepted and
if someone is making that decision you
may not know the reasons as to why they
are making that decisions and i would
say that we should respect it
next week
um you're both you and dr shahab and
fast have talked about this making your
personal risk assessment and
um but you basically just said that
people shouldn't
ask other people if they're vaccinated
or not anymore after this is gone um
and we're getting progressively less and
less data on kobit 19.
how are people supposed to make accurate
risk assessments for themselves if they
have so little data to go off of
do you want to speak to the data first
dr shahab and then i'll maybe speak to
the personal risk assessments and such
yeah so until data like i always used to
look at seven day averages and we used
to get seven day average data every day
but now i'll only get it on thursday so
i i will only
be looking at data for the most part
once um a week
and i think it is a bit of a different
you know we need to you
need to all get used to it like
i think ever since late february march
we've been looking at data every day and
people who are assembling that data were
getting up every day at 3am starting to
assemble at that data at 4am but
you know it was less and less useful on
a daily basis so certainly i think
this thursday we'll see our first
data cut and it may not be the final
format there will always obviously be
some feedback but i think that will tell
us in general terms you know what is the
state of omicron activity in the
province
and that will guide us
there will be one data
set that will guide us but then you know
many uh people already have seen in the
workplace's schools that the omicron
wave came and in most jurisdictions most
schools it has visibly passed like as we
discussed last week
it has peaked over the last week or two
hospitalizations are peaking
as we speak or a week or two and may go
up a bit for a week before they start
descending but all of that information
will be in that weekly summary that i
think will
give us better information uh which
which is which is adjusted to the way
omicron has been behaving but having
said that i think you know
we need to start visualizing how we will
manage
ourselves you know obviously uh starting
february 14th
you know uh
with
the the proof of vaccination no longer
required but that still be available
through our qr code for travel and if
you're another another country or
jurisdiction where it's it may still be
required and certainly i think we need
to start visualizing that you know the
current orders from molecules are in
place till february if our trends
continue uh you know there will be a
time where mask use will not be a
mandatory order and we should you know
start thinking about at work at school
how you know what our decisions would be
for ourselves our children
and again you know um we have been in
that place before several times during
the last 25 months now 26 months
and we will be again and it's just a
matter of you know becoming comfortable
where we see ourselves in in march but
obviously that information will be
available on a weekly basis
i think it will be a richer data set
given
how the reporting had to change with
omicron but again let's see on thursday
how it is and obviously
it
will continue to get adapted according
to you know what data is more useful
which is in many ways uh
you know how
public health manages many other
communicable or transmissible diseases
that we have in this province each and
uh each and every year and and and they
will use the same uh alerting mechanisms
that they have should a community or a
for instance a
center or something someone have to be
alerted in in some way shape or form we
do this with many other uh communicable
diseases uh today um
just in your question then you had said
you know should should we or should we
not be asking uh people whether or not
they're vaccinated and and i have no
opinion on that what i am saying is is
we shouldn't be um as we move forward
and we truly want to get back to to
normal uh we shouldn't be dwelling or
focusing in on um you know what other
people's decisions are
we each should do our own personal risk
assessment as we find our way through uh
the next number of weeks i would put
forward that saskatchewan people are in
many cases and families are doing that
already and wherever anyone lands on
that
the decisions that they make coming out
of that personal risk assessment and
maybe wearing a mask to an event it may
be not attending the event and maybe you
know attending the event
in you know under certain circumstances
that their their family is uh is
comfortable with what i am saying is um
we should get back to a time um where we
were pre-covered where we accept the
fact that other people are making uh the
decisions they are for themselves and
and possibly for their family um and and
we should respect that um when we see
people with a mask it's normalized um we
should by no means whether or not you're
wearing a mask or not post february 28th
um you know judge or in any way um think
that that that that is an issue that
someone is wearing a mask that's where
they have landed for whatever their
reasons are with
the where they feel safe in that
particular environment
and we as individuals in saskatchewan
should always accept that except the
fact that you know other people are
going to be making those decisions they
may be somewhat different than the
decisions we're making um but but we
respect them for that
full of questions
before my follow-up you mentioned matt
like not wearing masks after february is
that a for sure that masks are lifting
on february 28th yeah the the public
health order around masking will be
expiring on february the 28th and we're
not looking at renewing it
so it won't be renewed um and then my
follow-up um
on january 12th uh premier you extended
the existing mentors
to the end of february uh and on january
26th dr johan said we should stay the
course with those existing measures for
another four to six weeks to prevent a
rebound of copen what's changed since
then that we feel we should drop those
now and not have a rebound
i think we're right within that four to
six weeks maybe a week earlier on the
proof of acts but we're right in the
middle of that four to six weeks
uh january 26 to february 28th
is uh is over four weeks
and uh the proof of acts i guess we've
pulled pulled forward about two weeks
and then it's the decisions that we've
made collectively with respect to you
know where we are where society is and
ultimately uh the effectiveness of the
public health orders that we have in
place
and the tools that saskatchewan people
have in place to utilize uh in in
conducting their personal risk
assessment each and every day um we have
widespread access to vaccines
among the highest booster dose rate in
the country in particular a very high
booster dose rate of uptake in our
elderly we have
rapid tests available we have
early intervention therapies that were
not available even prior to christmas in
any degree monoclonal antibodies as well
as paxlovit
all of these are available to ensure
that we can one
move back to a much more normal op
environment in our daily lives and two
uh to ensure that um should someone get
omicron we have the tools available to
uh to keep them out of hospital and keep
the the symptoms as unsevere as as
possible
what i i'm saying here today as well as
as we find our way uh through uh the the
last of the the two public health orders
that we have in the month of february is
if we truly are to go back to a place
where we were in our
friend group in our family groups in our
communities and in our province
24 months ago just prior to when covet
hit we all need to make an extra effort
to to understand and respect everyone
everyone's right to make their own
decision
next we'll go to jeremy
yes thank you um premier how much
influence did the convoy protest have on
this decision today how much how much
which does it have how much how much
influence did it have on the decision i
i don't think uh
like there's multiple convoys that are
happening in in in various areas of the
province and and you know i think many
politicians have spoken to you know
separating out some individuals comments
in each of those convoys uh from
uh the broader uh effort and initiative
of of people that are attending those
convoys to have their their voice heard
like like any other protest and i've
been clear around uh instructing and
asking all of them to to follow the
rules or ultimately face the
consequences from
law enforcement officials i think uh
when when you look at influence in the
decision that the government is is
making uh today
there is influence from people across
the province i would say not
specifically uh convoys but we have a
you know a large number of mlas on on
the saskatchewan party uh on the
governing side and they have been
talking to their constituents for well
throughout this pandemic since the time
they've been elected but i've been
listening and listening very closely in
particular the changes in in in uh
trends and reasoning uh behind um
um
you know people's comments to their mla
as well as listening to and we've often
talked about the consequences of public
health orders the unintended
consequences of public health orders uh
you know listening to uh you know
families uh at times very uh you know
very impactful stories around um some of
those uh consequences ultimately
you blend that with the the science
that we have
when you look at the omicron wave being
very different than the the delta wave
and i said in my opening comments we
were
reluctant to bring in a policy like this
because it is a dis divisive policy it
does segregate uh people in in our
communities and in our society um and
when you look at the effectiveness of
that of that policy it proved to be very
effective in finding our way through the
delta wave increased our our vaccination
rates markedly uh here in the in the
province um as you look at the
challenges with of transmissibility with
the omicron wave and the the case counts
uh that we have whether they be
vaccinated or unvaccinated this this
policy most certainly has run its course
and so it's it's time for us to move to
the next uh the next steps or the next
stage of covid and that is one that
doesn't include a proof of vaccination
policy so um with to answer your
question on on you know any convoy
individuals uh yes uh have an influence
as they uh talk to their respective mlas
uh whether or not they're in a convoy
they're still individuals and and we we
respect that
uh just a follow-up question um you're
talking about division and the division
we've been seeing
uh with your previous you know support
of these protests do you think at all
you participated in any of this division
in the province well i think you know
aside from uh some individuals that have
done some uh really despicable acts
and they should be held accountable for
those uh the the bulk of what you're
seeing in not all of these uh protests
but some of them um and i would go back
a couple of weeks to the one in regina
uh th these are just saskatchewan people
um that
you know see the divisions in their
family and the friends groups and in
their communities and they're willing to
move forward uh living with whatever
risk uh is is is there with kovid
and we're minimizing that by providing
uh the tools for people to use in their
personal risk assessment but they're
willing to move forward uh without the
public health orders uh to to move away
uh from some of the you know the
divisions that we ultimately are seeing
and so what saskatchewan is doing today
is providing a you know a plan uh how we
are going to move away
from our public health orders over the
course of the next um
about three weeks i suspect you'll see
other provinces do something similar in
in the next while and i you know i would
ask the federal government as well on
behalf of of all canadians uh to you
know continually be revisiting uh the
any of the orders that they have in
place as to uh their effectiveness and
uh and ultimately the the other impacts
the
uh the other consequences uh that may uh
be evident from from some of those
public health orders i think it's
incumbent on all of us as governments to
put the public health orders in when
they're necessary and those aren't easy
decisions but we're also incumbent to
remove them when they have run their
course and that is what we're seeing
here in saskatchewan
go to conor next i believe mandatory
self-isolation is attached to the same
public health order that masking is so
that public health order is expiring is
mandatory self-isolation also funding
yeah all of the public health orders
will expire on february the 28th
mandatory self-isolation has not been
something that has
you know largely been enforced
throughout the covet pandemic started at
14 days down to 10 and now ultimately at
5.
listen saskatchewan people um
they know what's required of them to to
find our our way back to a normal
environment it involves regular testing
and we have rapid tests available i did
one again early this week
and it involves when you do test
positive that you isolate yourself for
for a period of five days so that you're
not uh spreading covet to other people
and it's our expectation that uh
saskatchewan people are going to
continue going to continue to do what
they've been doing
for quite a period of time now do you
have any other comments on that dr shaw
no i think you know
the few people who will be going for pcr
testing obviously they'll be in a
clinical pathway anyway and and like the
premier said the vast majority who were
either staying home because they were
symptomatic
and not even
accessing rapid antigen testing or
accessing rapid energy they've been
isolating there's been no notification
or enforcement process for that anyway
so you know i don't
think that order expiring will have any
you know
significant impact and we have to
remember that
now code will be like living with code
means that code will be like so many
other
diseases that we may on occasion get um
you know we stay home if we have a call
for cold or flu
if we have you know
really sometimes you know if we have
pertussis or measles you know the
specific isolation criteria for that
which public health advisors so similar
provisions
follow-up question connor yeah i'd be
crossing into sha territory a bit but i
think the other remaining uh sort of
measure restriction if you will is you
know the uh
level of legislation restrictions at
long-term care homes and personal care
homes so should residents in those
spaces expect to continue that level of
precaution being taken i know a lot of
them are here
obviously they want to see their family
that kind of thing so what's uh i guess
the future looks like there dr schwab
you might have some more specific
comments on this i'm not certain but
i should clarify that what we're doing
today uh is uh on sunday february the
13th at midnight the proof of
vaccination proof of negative tests
policy will be removed for all customers
as well as employees in any provincial
provincially regulated uh workspace on
february 28th the the
the public health order will not be
removed
thus on march the first masking will no
longer be mandatory
in
schools public places everywhere we are
working safe for within saskatchewan
health authority
facilities and the saskatchewan health
authority is working right now on
operating environments as we move
forward in our long-term care centers
for example and all of our health
authority facilities
as to
you know how they ensure that those
facilities understanding some of our
most vulnerable family members are in
them
ensure the safety but also ensure the
access for family members to continue to
see
their loved ones uh in the days ahead so
there'll be more to come specific on the
saskatchewan health authority in the uh
in the weeks ahead
what we're talking about today is
everything else
so what wouldn't be covered with today's
announcements would be federally
regulated industries such as
transportation telecommunications um and
and the saskatchewan health authority is
working on their own distinct plan
everything else would be covered with
today's announcement
and next stop from the job i guess what
should you think should happen there
so every coffin cold season special
provisions apply for long-term care
facilities clinical environments
obviously depending on the nature of the
environment specific provisions apply
which will continue
and then if there's an outbreak or other
concern in that area either in the
facility or in that area then you know
further precautions may be placed but
that will again apply to uh for the most
part in long-term care facilities
clinical areas
where you know there are people at high
risk
who really can't control the environment
unlike individuals can but as the
premier said i think some of that
clarity will come over the
next few weeks
next we go to mickey yeah um in november
there was a law passed to protect
employers from lawsuits when asking for
proof of acts or negative tests i was
just wondering if that law will still
protect employers who choose to keep
their vaccine policy and can businesses
or employers keep their backs policy or
mask mandate um well i won't advise them
as to whether or not they can keep speak
to the vaccine policy first of all maybe
the masking policy first of all with
respect to masking if a
you know if a private business chooses
to have a masking policy in place to
enter that private business there's
really nothing the government can do
customers would make their choices to
whether they
they attend that business or not with
resp respect to something that is quite
different and that's uh requiring a
proof of a health record uh for entry uh
it is the the goal of this government
that no one whether it be a teacher or
student in school whether it be an
employee or whether it be a
a a
potential customer of a business is
required to
um provide a health record uh to gain
entry uh to that building so the uh the
regulations that were in place uh
indemnifying uh businesses for to act on
the proof of vaccination policy for
customers and for employees
should be considered temporary i mean it
will be removed post february the 13th
so if a business should
want to consider with a proof of
vaccination or proof of negative test
policy
my advice to them would be to consult
their lawyer because the government is
removing any
temporary protections that we had in
place
and that is that is to create
a unified access uh to schools to
businesses and to our communities for
all saskatchewan residents and follow up
mickey
um yeah if maybe both of you play on in
this way and on this question but we've
heard the risks of coping 19 measures
are starting to outweigh
the benefits of them
what impacts are they starting to have
on society or other areas of public
health
you want to speak to that doctor
yeah so um i i i think
you know in terms of
the this is a
you know this question has many levels
of answers
like in the healthcare system i think
you know whenever our hospital has gone
up
you know for
specific periods of time there have been
other service slowdowns that then have
had to catch up so that's
on the healthcare side on the public
health side i think public health teams
have been trying to make sure that
childhood vaccines remain uh up to date
but we've seen in other parts of the
world that you know there's been measles
outbreaks for example so again there's a
message to all parents i think what we
have seen is that for the most part
childhood vaccines have been keeping up
to date but again that is critical as
well uh you know we've talked a lot
about mental health supports that they
need to continue there there's you know
there were challenges accessing them
they were addressed by the sha and other
partners
so that's on the healthcare side but i
think on the other
uh you know
again
this is not for me to comment on
exclusively from a public health
perspective but you know i think the
impact that
especially in the early days of the of
the pandemic the impact it had on
children in terms of not being able to
be in class in terms of in-person
learning the fact that maintaining
in-person learning was their priority
and that once school started you know
mask use was a feature for the last two
school years it was the third school
year where children have been wearing
masks consistently and really well and
obviously i think it's really important
to support children as we transition in
march so that you know it's perfectly
fine to not wear a mask if a child wants
to wear a mask or has a medical
condition for which they need to wear
masks again it should not be an issue
either way
and and of course you know it is always
a challenge to slow down
extra critical activity sports we try to
do that as little as as little as
possible but again you know now that
other activities for children are
picking up i think that is going to be
essential
for you know normal childhood
development and again i think this week
in class you know learning started at
the university of saskatchewan
may start at some point of ufr but again
you know all these things are critical
things uh in terms of and
you know
growth and development for children and
young adults
which i think is it's important that
they proceed in a way that
may be a bit different than it was in
2019 but you know as
close to living with kowitt as we can
i would just add to that the you know
the decisions that we've made and other
governments have made throughout the
covert pandemic have always been with an
eye to
do everything we can to protect our
health care system by also
keeping things as as close to normal as
as possible
you know as we move forward there's
plans in place that we've talked about
publicly with respect to how we are
increasing some of the capacity within
our health care system
you know we have a an increase in our
our surgeries uh that is planned and has
been publicly communicated increase in
our our icu beds our icu capacity in
saskatchewan and i think you'll see some
of that across canada as canada's you
know in our our publicly uh funded
publicly delivered health care system uh
we have far too low of icu census when
you uh correlate that to other
other countries around the world that is
going to take additional staff and so
we're working right now on you know
increa necessary increases to various
training programs is there recruitment
opportunities for you know people to
come here and work in our health care
system to ensure that our health care
system is resilient as we
as we move forward um and and working
closely with other provinces to have it
properly funded from the federal
perspective through the canada health
transfer but dr shahab has spoken you
know to the divisions uh um we said
earlier there there's folks that are at
times have been unable to see their
um their family in in in their health
care system or in our long-term care
homes and uh
you know that has been challenging we're
finding our way through that here today
there's been divisions in our
communities uh the convoys came up you
know we have convoys literally in every
province i to my understanding across
the nation we have borders that are
being blocked
and multiple uh multiple areas and these
are
uh for in a large part people that want
these divisions ultimately uh to to go
away
and every day
we wake up in this nation focused on the
latest coven numbers the latest covet
hospitalizations and you know as we
truly try to find our way through
um
our past um it's it's it's going to take
some effort on
for each of us uh in in what we do uh in
our our daily lives there's children dr
shahab had referenced you know the
growth and development of children has
been impacted over the course of the
last 20 months
at times they haven't been able to go to
school they haven't been able to
participate in anything extracurricular
and we most certainly
don't want to experience
that
again we want things to be as as normal
as they possibly can and that's what
today's announcement is about and it's
going to take some effort i've said this
many times today this is going to take
some effort
from each of us as individuals and we
prov we've given this effort before
on a daily basis i was reading through
some quotes uh the other day and there's
one that i i think
you know really summarizes where uh the
canadian population uh is today and and
hopefully maybe where their head space
would be as we as we look ahead and it's
from uh
if there ever was a great politician
winston churchill i think would uh be in
the running um and it goes like this and
i quote if we open a quarrel between
past and present we shall find that we
have lost the future
that most certainly is where we are in
saskatchewan we have a great future to
look forward to we have the opportunity
uh if if we all are
doing our daily risk assessments
respecting other people's opinions and
decisions um we have the opportunity to
truly lead canada through this latest
wave of omicron uh covet variant uh we
also have the opportunity in this
province we've seen the various
investment announcements uh to really
lead this nation and to lead the world
in a fulsome economic recovery uh
providing like quite likely better
careers for for many of us and better
careers ultimately career opportunities
for that next generation our children if
we come together saskatchewan can really
be on full display as to you know what a
community uh what a province and
ultimately what a nation can achieve uh
in
you know in in in what is
following
a very very challenging uh 20 or 22
months
next week lisa
um
i guess why the rush i mean it was going
to end at the end of february anyway the
proof of vaccination so what i guess
positives are you or the people of the
province going to be getting in those
two weeks that wouldn't be outweighed
by giving those two weeks to hospitals
to maybe get some more breathing room
yeah i i don't think the dr shahab you
might have comment on this i i i don't
think public health measures when
they're implemented or when they're
they're removed both are difficult
decisions uh are ever
uh considered uh you know solely on on
on a calendar time frame
there's there's you know many other
factors that go into those decisions
what you know where you're where's the
case counts where's the hospitalizations
what's the trajectory of those what
tools do you ultimately have available
and and we we feel at this point in time
with the declining trajectory in our
numbers which are
as of sunday which was the last day uh
numbers were released we're down
um our seven day averages it was down 42
percent our our hospitalizations down 12
our icu emissions down 16 as of uh last
sunday um so as our trajectory is on a
the the appropriate uh um
on on in in the right direction uh we
you know we ultimately feel that this is
the time to
come out today make the announcements
around the proof of vaccination policy
that will be ending
this sunday at midnight that provides
government some time to change some
regulations it provides businesses
sometimes to make the necessary
changes in their place of business for
both their customers as well as their
employees and ultimately uh providing uh
the the the opportunity for masking
through till the end of february um uh
will allow these numbers to you know
further uh decrease uh over the course
of the next number of weeks
there was some discussion raised by the
minister of education as well around the
fact that we do have a a week holiday in
our schools at the end of february
where there will be no student or
student or for the most part staff in in
the school facilities as well and so it
our students and our staff will go into
that holiday with a mandatory masking
measure in place and we'll come out of
that that week off with without one
where it will be lifted
that's not to say that some individuals
students and staff may still be wearing
masks and that's fine i think mask
wearing is very much normalized in our
society and i i'm certain in some in
some instances many instances you will
see a certain portion of of students and
staff that will remain wearing masks
post that february 28th date and i think
all in all providing uh the the plan
over the course of the next number of
weeks uh just provides us all with a
a little bit of an opportunity to think
about
um
what it truly means in getting back to
normal and and and part of that is
we're all going as i said many times
today we're all going to be doing those
personal risk assessments um and we also
need to remember that that other people
are doing them as well and they may come
to a different conclusion and we need to
you know accept accept that and we'll
certainly respect the fact that they
have landed where they have landed
follow-up lisa
yeah i think you know first of all you
know if the delta wave had ended like it
did in december and omicron had never
come about we probably would have exited
these measures you know earlier
of course omicron came when it did
first in
you know other parts of the world and in
other provinces and then late december
in saskatchewan um we did need to
understand how omicron is different
and once we understood that obviously it
became quite apparent like has been
discussed you know at length last week
in in the technical briefing that you
know once you're more than three months
out from your second dose
you know the the benefit to reducing
hospitalization persists but the benefit
for
getting mild illness or transmitting
goes down significantly
and is you know very low by six months
post your second dose a boosted dose
does increase your significantly your
booster dose decreases significantly
your risk of hospitalization
in every age group but especially if
you're older or have risk factors so
that's why you know getting your boosted
dose at every age you know 12 and older
but especially if you have even mild
underlying risk factors or if you're
older i think will is will remain
critical and we have to remember that
boosted doses were one of the first
province to uh open up booster tools in
an age-based risk-based fashion there
was no requirement to get a boost to
those but you know
it was not covered by the proof of
vaccination but we have had a very
significant uptake of boosted doses that
will
you know
serve individuals who have received the
boosted dose well and will reduce
pressure and hospitalizations
going forward we hope all the way into
fall by which time you know there may be
other considerations based on what's
happening at that time
um so for with all those perspectives in
in in in mind you know there's
never you know there can always be some
back and forth
in terms of when actually
uh an order can be lifted but as the
previous said you know the government's
decision was to lift that um you know uh
13th of february uh and same you know
the um discussion on the the
the molecules uh
we
four weeks ago we were looking at the
trajectory of omicron in the uk and
ontario quebec you know very quick
search up we were getting up for that
rapid increase in hospitalizations which
again happened in saskatchewan but with
the two measures that we had in place
and without any additional measures
i think our trajectory and this again is
a credit to
the people of saskatchewan the fact that
they have been you know staying home
with the unwell seeking self-testing
getting the booster doors our trajectory
of case numbers as much as we can
determine you know wastewater
surveillance hospitalizations
it is actually tracking um better than
even the most optimistic scenarios
and i think that is that is quite
significant obviously you know we still
need to stay the course till the end of
february in terms of the orders that
remain and even after that i think
people at high risk need to you know
assess the risk get a sense of
what is the transmission in saskatchewan
and canada because at this point we
can't predict will automation
transmission of omicron go to
virtually undetectable level at some
point will it plateau at a certain level
where will there be ups and downs
eventually or locally and based on that
i think we'll have to continue to
readjust at an individual level and the
implications for long-term care
facilities in terms of will they
continue to see outbreaks in march april
all of that we can't predict but i think
you know those things will continue to
be monitored and and and you know
the epi summary will speak to all of
those uh things but i think right now
the trajectory is looking quite
favorable towards the end of february
but again staying the course for the
next three weeks is going to be
important and and again you know i i
always say that you know the
vaccinations remain available we are
very privileged in um in canada compared
to other parts of the world and to have
vaccines available for everyone five
years and older and boosted those every
for everyone 12 and older and i think
taking advantage of that will serve as
well as individuals as families as
communities and reduce the pressure on
the health system all the way into the
fall and of course you know as long as
there's a global pandemic if there's
anything that is different anytime into
the future you know we will be
monitoring that and we'll have to adjust
accordingly
we've kind of seen this before last july
we took down all health measures and
then cases went up again so
are you anticipating the cases are going
to go up once these public health
measures are gone and if they do
what is the threshold for putting
health measures back in and are you
going to be
how much is
the response to the fourth wave going to
be kind of in your head as you're
watching that
so i'll uh i'll maybe make a comment dr
schaub and you might have some comments
as well listen if there's another wave
that comes you know we'll assess what
that wave uh means and is uh at that
point in time
as far as transmissibility as far as uh
uh you know is it acting more like uh
delta with respect to the impact on on
the health care system or or more like
omicron or potentially even uh
maybe less
less uh
challenging than omicron from a
hospitalization perspective so if there
is another wave um and i believe maybe
we've seen part of one in in places like
denmark that was again much different
but we'll uh we'll manage our way
through that like we have uh every wave
uh thus thus far
uh significant difference between you
know now and anytime previous are the
tools that we
that we ultimately have available in in
saskatchewan and to the degree that
saskatchewan people are utilizing those
tools and understanding
the factors that go into their their
risk assessment each and every day we
have a much higher vaccination rate we
have booster doses that are available
the vaccines are available to a much
broader age group uh that than at any
time uh previous
we have rapid tests available in this
province unlike virtually anywhere else
in in canada we have early intervention
therapies that will help people
ultimately that do uh get covered and
may be immunocompromised
in keeping their symptoms as uh
as uh not as severe as as we possibly
can and none of those tools were
available when we look back over the the
months and now years that we've been
managing our way through covet and and
you know dr shahab said something a
moment ago that i think really deserves
a shout out and credit to what
saskatchewan people are doing uh each
and every day
we didn't attain uh some of the the
forecasts that we thought would be
attained here in saskatchewan in the way
of of not only case numbers but but
hospitalizations and and we did so when
you look across canada with a very
different suite of public health
measures in place than than what we saw
in virtually
every other province the ones that were
in place
proved to be helpful and the
but what really i think
has allowed
us to
be
at the levels that we're at and be able
to ultimately make an announcement like
we are today is the fact that
saskatchewan people have been paying
attention and they are
conducting themselves uh you know very
responsibly they're self-isolating when
when they test positive they're some are
even uh you know self-isolating for a
day or two if they're a contact people
are are doing the right things out there
people are negative testing um i i
cannot um and i'm thrilled but i cannot
believe the amount of personal at-home
rapid tests that are being utilized
when they're necessary by individuals
and families and how they're breaking
that up in amongst their family where
one is testing at a certain point and as
to preserve the tests that we have and
so credit to saskatchewan people
for everything that they're doing and i
i
i think it is
any any positives that have come through
the omicron wave in not achieving some
of the
some of the forecasted hospitalization
levels is because saskatchewan people
have have been responsible each and
every day and the fact that we're out
here today charting a course through the
last couple of public health measures we
have
would not be happening if saskatchewan
people had not conducted themselves as a
as as a group uh in in such a
responsible way over the course the last
number of weeks and months so uh thank
you to each of them uh dr schaub
anything to add on that yeah i just said
that you know based on our weekly
reports on other you know evidence that
people uh hear about in the communities
how frequently we do you know even
antigen testing may you know stabilize
at a certain level or go down or march
april uh obviously weekly reports will
continue and then go down to monthly but
you know further to your question if
there's again a
sense that you know there's an increase
in transmission that information will be
made available so maybe
people who had reduced doing their
antigen testing because things are
settled down may restart doing that or
may change how they wear mass or you
know that that will remain throughout
the
later part of the spring and summer and
again we
expect in the fall you know we can't
predict anything with certainty but in
the fall likely there may be a
resurgence of um kovad either the same
variant or
a subclade of that you know the premium
i think was referring to ba2 which we've
seen small amounts of transmission but
that that has you know taken over to a
significant degree in denmark but has an
increase in hospitalizations and has
plateaued at a certain level
uh
less to a lesser degree in the uk so all
those things i think our lab partners
will be monitoring will be monitoring
we'll be publishing a lot of that
information on our weekly reports or
through special reports as required that
will help all of us decide what we need
to do march april and and onwards
thank you we have time for a few more
questions uh so we'll get to as many as
we can on the phone uh operator
we have adam hunter with cbc
thanks for taking my question uh for the
premier i just wanted to clarify earlier
you were talking about uh you know
private businesses school divisions you
know municipalities just want to be
clear what what are they going to be
allowed to do
as far as proof of vaccination and
masking going forward past march 1st or
i guess past monday with proof of
vaccination then pass march 1st will
they be allowed to put in their own
policies will will it depend or is the
government saying that's not going to be
allowed
you mentioned lawyers at one point yeah
what i what i said adam and thank you
for the opportunity to clarify is
the government has put in in place
some protection for businesses i believe
for municipalities and the provincial
government
to enact the the proof of vaccination
proof of negative test policy
throughout the when it has been in place
in in the pandemic that regulation will
be repealed on uh
effective uh midnight february the 13th
and so the provincial government will
not be moving forward with any proof of
vaccination proof of negative test in
any of for any of our provincial
employees past that point or any
customers that enter a provincial
business or operation of any kind
will not be required uh to provide that
that proof of vaccination or proof of
negative test if a municipality or a
private business wanted to move forward
with that policy
i suppose they should do so my advice
would be to consult a lawyer
because the protections that the
provincial government provided will no
longer be there and they may open
themselves up to some vulnerability and
so i won't provide advice or say whether
you know private businesses
is
free to do uh what they uh choose uh but
they they also may have some
consequences that would be a result of
that our goal as a government is uh to
provide access um in
uh much like we had uh 24 months ago
previous to to to covet being here
access for example for our our all of
our teachers and our students to attend
school and all of the staff that are in
our schools without providing that proof
of vaccination proof of negative tests
but also to provide access uh to
you know our our community uh facilities
uh whether they be municipally owned
whether they be privately owned um and
restaurants and businesses uh retail
whether that be an employee or whether
that be a uh a customer so the the
government's goal is uh for for would be
for
uh uh in an ideal world for for no one
to be enacting uh the proof of
proof of uh vaccination or proof of
negative test policy but in the case of
private business uh they're free to make
their decisions and my advice is uh to
consult some legal counsel on what the
consequences of that decision might be
and you have a follow-up adam
yeah also for the premier uh
the last night the organizers of the
convoy in ottawa expressed you know what
they had put out in their memorandum of
understanding earlier that they seek
uh you know to talk to the governor
general seek a correlation with the
other parties never to oust a
democratically elected government
and you spoke earlier about individuals
that are you know uh causing you know
problems with some of the conways and
protests but i want to know what your
opinion of this is given that this this
latest uh information from this convoy
is is coming out publicly
and it's uh causing a lot of problems in
the nation's capital yeah
um they they're intently causing uh
challenges in the nation's capital um
and i believe it's spreading uh to other
areas as well i understand that the
bridge between windsor and detroit has
been at least slowed as well or at least
it was last evening i haven't checked
here yet this morning and so uh you know
the sentiment is is spreading and really
uh this is that that sentiment of
of division and uh sentiment of the the
broader population of people uh you
don't want to have a
i want the government uh to have a a
conversation with them about what this
looks like in the in the weeks and
months ahead and that is what we're
doing uh here in saskatchewan today as
far as
overthrowing a democratically elected
government i don't know that that's
going to happen
but
you know most certainly
in spite of some individuals that need
to be held accountable for for actions
that are are unbecoming of of canadians
the
uh the the the majority of uh you know
people i think uh most certainly are in
in
to some degree supportive of what has
started as a
um you know a protest against a
mandatory vaccination policy no proof of
negative test option but a mandatory
vaccination policy expansion uh to the
transport industry
and but is expanded really you know
across communities to you know the whole
discussion about where we are with the
public health orders that we have in
place and i think people want the all
levels of government to be very frank
with them as to what the benefit is what
the cons inadvertent cons consequences
are of these uh
of these policies and and when can we
look for in light of reducing number you
know numbers decreasing across canada uh
when can we look for a an expiration
date on these policies and attempting to
get uh you know life as we know it back
to some degree of normalcy what i've
said today and and what i would say to
uh everyone uh whether it be folks in
the federal government uh on all
in all parties um or or the folks that
are in uh the actual convoys
is
uh you know as we find our way through
these mandates and i believe we will in
the weeks ahead
at all levels uh we need to make every
effort to you heal some of the divisions
that have been created in our in our
communities and uh you know that's
that's the message that i would like to
send uh everyone uh today as we find our
our way what will hopefully be uh you
know the last number of weeks of the of
the omicron wave is that we have some
work to do
we have some work to do in this province
we have some work to do as individuals
and our families and friendship groups
and we have some work to do as canadians
on uh you know healing some of these
divisions and putting our best forward
foot forward so that we can
really capitalize on some of the
opportunities that lie before us
and we'll take our next question on the
line
we have stephanie davis with ctv
hi there um a question for dr shahab um
just a little bit more on schools we've
seen cases
uh spreading so quickly through schools
and classrooms
so i guess my question is just
why should parents feel safe sending
their kids to school with no
restrictions in place
yeah thank you for that so first of all
you know obviously we are having
discussions within uh
the country on moving forward living
with kowitt that includes a really
important sector schools that
is important for in-person learning with
appropriate provisions and we've always
talked talked about the layered approach
in schools and actually over the weekend
i was also talking to colleagues
and and and actually parents
of children who go to school in the uk
for example and so in the uk for example
they have navigated their way out of
omicron with you know mass not no longer
being required but being optional with
antigen testing being being encouraged
but not required and
and if there's a local increase in
transmission in a part of the uk
and there's more mass use if the
transmission goes down there's less
and i think that is
the most
likely way that we will have to navigate
in march where some parents may choose
to have their children continue to use
mars
others not so much
but i think it is important for us to at
least as as
and there's been discussions education
already and you know me and my
colleagues medical health officers will
continue to have those discussion with
school boards but i think it is
important for school
divisions and and for parents to start
thinking ahead and for teachers about
how
much will look and feel like and be able
to choose to wear a mask or not wear a
mask
and of course we already know that a lot
of extracurricular activities have
already picked up
and that's great
and finally
and i think i said that earlier many
people have seen
that you know in most communities the
omicron wave peaked a week or two ago
and
has passed or is passing so i think
that's another thing that over the next
two or three weeks as
that really uh
[Music]
has passed and there's a sense that
there's very little
illness in schools being reported either
through staff absenteeism or children
being absent
i think that will lend confidence to you
know moving ahead
without a
mandatory mask policy in schools as well
you have a follow-up question stephanie
yes thank you um one for the premier i'm
just wondering if you can talk a little
bit about the consultation process in
coming to this decision uh we heard from
a number of unions uh around the
province yesterday just who were calling
for the restrictions to stay in place so
i'm just wondering if your government
consulted with groups on making this
decision or if it was just uh something
that you guys decided many ultimately it
was a government decision at the end of
the day um the about we have consulted
not only uh with a number of groups
uh yes uh organized labor
representatives from across the province
our minister of education has been in
constant contact with in particular ssba
board members
as well as our our economic ministers
have been in contact with various
associations across the the business
profile here in saskatchewan as well as
and i've said this many times before but
we had emphasized it again throughout
the new year uh our mlas have been in
contact with with various organizations
and associations within each of their
constituencies whether it be uh you know
local organizations
as well as individuals many many many
individuals over the course of the last
number of months and so all of that
input that we receive as a
democratically elected government that
we receive on behalf of our of our
constituents and various organizations
that are representative in our our
communities in our province proper uh
yes has uh those conversations have
occurred there won't be a hundred
percent agreement uh with whatever uh
the government had decided at the end of
the day and that's why but ultimately
the government uh does have to come to a
decision and we did um we came to a
decision as a caucus uh and and we
blended all of that with ultimately uh
the the the public health orders uh that
we have in place uh the effectiveness of
those public health orders and the uh
you know ultimately the the advice that
we that we continue to receive uh from
all of those in the in the health sector
and so they you know the decision has
been made by uh government to move
forward in this fashion to lay out this
uh you know that what the next three
weeks look like in saskatchewan uh we
feel we're able to get to this point
because of what saskatchewan people have
done as individuals and collectively as
a
society and and we're positive uh we're
confident pardon me
we're confident that uh you know this is
a is this is a path that is is good for
saskatchewan and will be supported
ultimately by the the majority of the
people in the province
and we have time for one more operator
we have murray mandrake with leader post
good morning mr premier
uh twenty four thousand six hundred
people
uh
were added to the job role in january uh
which i think you noted
that suggests that whatever you've been
doing economically at least in relation
to
uh the uh policies related to vaccines
and passports and masking has worked or
it was working so i guess what i want to
know is from an economic standpoint
what's the justification to changing
things now if what you were doing is
actually kind of working i don't i you
know and thank you for noting the fact
that uh we have had an eye to the opera
you know expanding our our economic
opportunities uh throughout this
pandemic and when you blend that with uh
some of the data that dr shahab had
provided uh with respect to how
saskatchewan people have conducted
themselves through the last number of
months and and how that is manifested in
in uh a lower uh rate of of uh
hospitalizations that that we were
expecting in the province um you know
kudos to to the people of this province
because they have allowed in doing so
have allowed our our economy to continue
to expand and a number of jobs to become
available when you look ahead
uh
and and the investments that are you
know already committed to the province
and some of that work is already
underway uh in here in in regina and at
other sites um and and more to come i i
would say more investments uh to come in
the uh in the weeks in the months ahead
that saskatchewan has a you know a great
opportunity not only to find our way uh
through the the last public health
measures we have in this omicron wave
but to find our way uh
as a as a leader in this nation and
around the world in
the global economic recovery that
ultimately is likely already underway
saskatchewan most certainly is going to
participate in that
one of the other aspects is not directly
economically related
but very much is something that we've
heard uh from from people myself as an
mla as well as a number of other
government mlas and i suspect opposition
mlas uh as as well is uh
they just
they do want things to get back to
normal but they do want things um to uh
get back to normal in a
in in maybe a bold way but most
certainly a responsible way and that's
why we've laid out uh the next number of
weeks that's why we're not just removing
things uh here today we've laid out the
next number of weeks of
of uh where the decision
where the
where the public health orders will
actually be removed in a in a phased
fashion and and that's why today i've
spoken at great length that
we have another job to do with
saskatchewan people and that's that's
really to come together in an
unjudgmental way
to accept you know our friends and
family for the decisions that they've
made
and most certainly don't you know don't
lose a friend or a family member
due to this to this virus
we have an opportunity uh to really
be an understanding uh individual and
thereby
together an understanding society and
and really
you know in many ways i think lead our
nation through uh what is a very
divisive time right now
and last question mary
i think people have come together though
if you look at the if you look at the
number people have actually gone out and
get vaccinated what today's policy does
is placate those that don't want to get
vaccinated and i get that the
frustration and the struggle to get them
vaccinated but isn't that the source of
the problem the fights in the family uh
are over whether uh the outliers will
get vaccinated and put
other people at risk and we have a
thousand deaths so i guess the question
is what is the definition of bringing
saskatchewan people together when
saskatchewan people together come
together on the notion of getting
vaccinated doing the right thing and
today's policy seems to basically say
well if you didn't do the right thing
we're no longer uh going to do anything
that can do or we can there's no longer
anything we can do to enforce that how
is that i guess bringing people together
yeah the the just the basis of your
question actually murray i think speaks
to um
you know really the the challenge that
we need to get through in in ultimately
judging you know people in the in the
pro in in the province and in our
communities um just be whether or not
you got vaccinated is not the right
thing um
there are many people that have went out
and gotten vaccinated who disagree with
the divisions that come about from a
proof of vaccination policy or proof of
negative test policy and so what we are
doing here today is is saying that we
are going to move forward without that
policy we're going to understand that
each of us has made our our own
decisions on whether they're vaccinated
or not on whether they're going to wear
a mask or not post
february 28th and that's fine we accept
that decision and we respect you for
making that decision um and that's
that's totally fine um that is your
decision to make it's not for me uh to
make that decision for you nor is it for
me to comment on on what your uh
ultimate uh decision is um this is and
we're providing that plan on on on the
steps that we're going to take in the
next number of weeks and i'm asking
saskatchewan residents to most certainly
i think about how they are going to you
know address people if they see them
with a mask or or engage with their with
their family and friends in the days
ahead i think i would further ask
outside of the province of saskatchewan
and because we still will have mandates
here we still will have our federal
mandates here in the areas of
transportation telecommunications travel
um
that
that other levels of government
provincial governments i'm positive are
already looking at this about our
federal government also i i think needs
to have a you know a real conversation
about
what the next number of weeks and a
couple of months look like for for
canadians in the areas uh where where
they have leaned in uh with their
federal mandates which have
not had the negative test option um and
and where people have actually uh you
know in some cases lost their their
place of their their employment uh due
to to making uh whatever decision uh
they did so um i i disagree with the
premise of of of the question uh murray
i think as we move forward um this isn't
about whether or not you did the right
thing this is about all of us in society
moving forward together um as i said
many that are vaccinated don't agree
with the the the policies that are in
place um and i've talked to to many of
those individuals as it is so as we uh
you know look ahead in this province we
have
you know everything to attain and to
aspire to and we have all of that
opportunity before us uh
the only thing that would prevent us
from achieving all that we can be is for
us to be
arguing amongst ourselves uh let's come
together as friends let's not lose a
friend due to this virus let's come
together as family let's not lose a
family relationship uh
regardless of what conversations have
occurred over the last number of months
as we look ahead let's come together as
a communities
within a great province and achieve what
we know we can achieve it's the
opportunity is there for us
and thank you all for taking the time to
join us today that concludes our
availability
you